There is nothing more annoying to a mentor
than somebody who is a total and I mean a
TOTAL askhole.
Not the word you thought about before.
. . I can't believe Pat said this on the title.
No, no, askhole.
It's an actual word, and you know what it
means?
Let me tell you exactly what it means.
An askhole is somebody who constantly asks
your advice, yet does the complete opposite
of what you tell them.
You see, this is very important to me because
for many years, I'm a by-product of many different
mentors.
And one of the things I had was, I do not
want to lose good mentors.
I do not want to lose great advisers.
I do not want to lose people that pour into
me regularly.
And, I used to mentor this one person quite
a lot, and then one day, he and I had a conversation
together, and he said, "Hey Pat, I want to
be more accountable to you."
And I said, "What for?"
He said, "What do you mean?
I want to be more accountable to you."
I said, "What is your outcome of being accountable?"
So we can communicate more.
I said, "For what?
What's your outcome on the business side,
not personal side.
You can call me anything you want with my
family, with your family, friends, all this
other stuff because we have a relationship,
but I don't understand why in business you
want to be accountable to me."
He said, "Well, so you can give me direction."
I said, "Why would I give you any direction?"
He said, "Why wouldn't you give me direction?"
I said, "Why would I ever give you direction?"
And we went back and forth.
I said, "Listen, you don't understand.
You're a total askhole."
And he said, "Pat, how could you say that
to me?"
I said, "I want you to take a quick pause
and go online and search that word."
And he went online and there's silence.
And I said, "Are you reading it?"
He said, "I just read it."
I said, "Look, the last seven things, let
me remind you, the last seven conversations
we've had, that I've given you direction,
do you realize that you've done the complete
opposite of everything I told you the last
seven times?
The last seven times, you've done the opposite.
I am no longer in a place in my life -- I
have three kids all under the age of five,
I run a company with a lot of employees, a
lot of agents, partners, vendors, I have commitments
to people that I'm doing things for.
I don't have time to mentor people who are
askholes."
And we went back and forth.
I said, "So call me if you have family stuff
you want to talk to me about, because I care
for you, but on the business end, I just really
can't help you any more.
I wish you all the best."
"I can't believe this is how it is, Pat."
I said, "No, no.
You don't realize, there's a great thing,
when you find a mentor, who actually knows
what they're doing.
They have put tens of thousands of hours into
their business of becoming a master.
It is very difficult to find a great mentor.
When you do find a great mentor, that is teaching
you, be extremely coachable to them, especially
if it's somebody that you want their life,
their all-around life.
If this is somebody that's willing to take
the time to pour into you, and teach you,
just make sure that when they do, you're learning
from them and you're implementing what they
are teaching you, because there's one thing
you've got to keep in mind.
There's never, never, never, ever, ever, a
lack of supply of people who want to learn
from a mentor.
But there is absolutely, absolutely a lack
of supply of great mentors.
That is why those who end up finding a great
mentor have an edge over everybody else.
Because it saves them tens of thousands of
hours of mistakes that they would have made.
So my message to you is very simple.
If you have a great mentor, who has the lifestyle
that you want, they're making the money you
want to make, they have a great personal life,
they have a good family life, they're raising
kids, they're doing things that they're growing.
They're getting better.
They're always in it.
They're working.
They're not just sitting on the sidelines
in retirement mode, kicking back.
I'm talking, they're in the game.
And they're willing to pour into you, be extremely
coachable to them.
Do not be an askhole, until they decide to
move on and go mentor somebody else who is
willing to be coachable to them.
With that being said, this was a short episode,
if you have not yet subscribed to this channel,
please be coachable and subscribe to this
channel.
We're trying to get to 100,000 subs by August
31, completely missed Mario there, by a mile.
Subscribe to the channel, and if you've got
any thoughts, about this, if you choose to
be either one of the words that spells the
same exact way, minus the two letters, you
can comment on the bottom.
We welcome both.
And if you've got any questions about it,
comment on the bottom as well.
I will respond to most of them.
I try to get back to every single one of the
comments that we get on the bottom.
With that being said, thanks for watching
everybody, take care.
Bye bye.